uh so we're going to do a little uh
little mathematical trick that I'm
hoping that people will like and they'll
try out on their friends and family so
let's do it we're going to write out
four digit numbers so like this right
now you've got three four eight five
right but we'll take it in turn so give
me a four digit number you could you
could just shout out four digits if you
want come on you want one from me yeah
seven seven two one seven seven two one
uh and I'll come up with like a
different one like two two seven eight
give me another
one eight nine one
eight nine one and I'll come up with
another one like eight one something
eight right and we're gonna add these
together right we're gonna add these
together three four eight five seven
seven two one eight one
an eight there you go so we see what
that is let's see what the answer is
okay so the answer is the final answer
is twenty three thousand four hundred
and eighty three now before I started
the trick I made a prediction on that
strip of brown paper let's have a look
let's have a look at my prediction if I
open up my prediction
says
[Applause]
I predict 23 483
and then I think what you're meant to
say here is
right do you want to see how to do it so
we learn how to do it all right and then
people can do it to their face as well
all right did you notice I started it
off
so I picked a number to begin with
then you picked a number
then the number I picked after you and
we took it in turns the number I picked
the digits column by column add up to
nine
so seven two seven and two two and seven
one and eight
so these two together are equal to nine
thousand nine hundred and ninety nine
the next two rows I did the same thing
can you see the add up to nine I had the
zero there and you picked the nine and
that's nine thousand nine hundred and
ninety nine so the last four rows
together
are going to be just shy when this is
just shy of ten thousand
add them together it's just shy of
twenty thousand it's too short it's
nineteen thousand nine hundred and
ninety eight
so I knew that the last four numbers
were 19
998. so what I did to make the
prediction I had thought of this in
advance
and then I added 20 000 to it which is
quite easy to do because you put the
digit two at the beginning
and then because it's two less than
twenty thousand I subtract the number
two
so you put the digit two at the start
and then you subtract two
from the end and you can make your
prediction and you can look like a
mathematical genius
back to the chosen card you're just not
going to get far enough but what you
will do is you'll take off well let's
say twelve one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve and
then obviously you're gonna do the thing
with oh no that's not it it didn't work
boohoo the trick now is instead of
putting these back on top put them
underneath